اربع سنوات غابت فيها الفنانه عبله كامل
عن جمهوريها في مصر والوطن العربي كان اخر
ظهور تليفزيون لها في الجزء الخامس من
مسلسل سلسال الدم اما خارج الشاشه فابتعدت
كليا على التواجد في اي مناسبه فنيه مع
الحفاظ على عادتها في عدم ظهور باي لقاء
تلفزيوني او صحفي الدكتور اشرف زكي نقيب
المهن تمثيليه قال ان عبله كامل تمر بحاله
حزن شديده بعد وفاه صديقه مقربه لها خارج
الوسط الفني الفنان القدير التي قدمت اكثر
من 100 عمل في الدراما والسينما والمسرح
طلبت حتى تاجيل تكريمها في الدوره الاولى
لمهرجان القاهره للدراما التي انطلقت في
سبتمبر الماضي وذلك بسبب عدم قدرتها
واستعدادها للظهور في الوقت الحالي من غير
المعروف ما اذا كانت عبله كامل ستظهر
قريبا على الشاشه لكن ما يهم الان هو ان
تكون بصحه جيده وتعود لترسم البسمه على
الوجود من جديد
[موسيقى]